[Music]
in single struggles nerves Oh
single is anyone here single no no yeah
submitted by what kind of toast
sourdough brick toast what the hell's an
Asian show Oh like like sweet butter
bullsh mom and it's fluffy imagine like
half a loaf of bread that they didn't
cut out and it's just like like that big
like a brick and then they dig it out
and then what do they put inside like
ice cream oh [ __ ] sweet sometimes the
patella parting cart the Olive Garden
garlic toast oh yeah you know that's
thick yeah the authentic toast it's like
that but sweet yeah roughy on the inside
and you put toppings on it yeah yeah
dude we need to take them I'll [ __ ] it
up yeah you would dude you're probably
the phlegm stuff though cuz it's ask us
I don't care I'll do okay awesome
like her we're married now there are now
even more brutal dating trends ruining
romance for singles Oh what are dating
trends no have you ever like go thing
for example oh yeah is it a trend that
you're supposed to that's been happening
they just put a title on it
bingos chills [ __ ] Casper the ghost what
exactly is coasting so ghosting is when
you're like talking to someone you're
dating them you're like everything's
cool then out of nowhere you just
disappear oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ] up yeah
that's cuz [ __ ] people don't like
confrontation in today's Sun always tell
people hey were it's not working out
people don't like that though I didn't
feel like that I just didn't have the
[ __ ] decency to just be like uh yeah
just you're wasting my time
no so use the piece some people want
[ __ ] on reserve and then they they get
bored I'm in the back okay they do their
thing
oh really so that's not really ghosting
I like to have a [ __ ] on deck no
ghosting is your con no not but they
eventually an indie goes afterwards it
goes back and forth then they go goodbye
there's a term for that yo yo [ __ ] I
forgot what it's called
yo your [ __ ] because not in this one
but there's a term for that
it's like when you keep them on standby
silly-string [ __ ] yo yo what
silly-string posi that sounds disgusting
cuz we need just splatters all over the
place
[ __ ] on deck [ __ ] on deck son that's
what I do babe that's called marriage
marriage [ __ ] on dance marriage no it's
not this you can't have it whenever you
want it's whenever I want you to have it
really what I want man she got offended
ooh watch out yeah yeah you don't say
those things bar yeah thank you you ever
say the truth women don't like that oh
yeah it's true but just don't say that
oh okay whatever you're not even married
no one's gonna marry hey first of all
that is absolutely not true
she is bothering me right now for it I
just there's no she I've never seen her
I have videos with you and her in it Oh
does she know that she's in it she know
she's your girlfriend oh yeah she does
she's my guess that would be a great
twist that would be a weird twist that'd
be a great twist plot twist
she doesn't know that you guys are
together yeah ghosting happened when we
were young or - oh it happen all the
time all the time oh the music video
song called hate it acquitted it just
sounds cooler now what booty they are
tooted in the booty but that's quitting
it like never talking to them again not
even saying yeah vaporizing you don't
even say anything huh you didn't quit it
is the same thing as Evelyn you said
it's not ghosting yeah just in case you
guys didn't hear me earlier what Joe is
talking about when you have like the
yo-yo [ __ ] apparently it's called
cushioning [ __ ] on death looks you're
on deck we thought it'd take a savings
savings account for [ __ ] so here are
some new trends now or I guess new terms
for these these things that people do so
the first one is flexing this is when a
man or woman boasts about themselves
online to impress their date
it occurs before the first meeting and
men tend to do it more than women it's
not just been game that's like some
normal [ __ ] I don't know game it's like
when you're trying to make yourself look
like oh my life is like this online to
like impress well that's the whole
[ __ ] Internet I tell you what true so
everybody is flexing yeah everyone's
question online this might be
exaggerated like it's just straight
[ __ ] they they boast about like man
I got my frog but it's in the shop
though yeah [ __ ] like that like I'm so
bored
oh oh yeah
right let me posting this they've been
doing this listing on days though send
the girl 13 pictures of your dick yep
what in it not hard no no no in
increments so you're like hey I couldn't
get it all on one haha so here's all
here it is it all together it's just the
Instagram pilot there you go Steve
here's just that swipe it here's just
like a little tidbit and a little tip
for you if all the guys in the room
agree with you it's a [ __ ] dumb idea
we tell you something good for you baby
yeah that's the only thing [ __ ] love
more than getting rings is getting dick
pics I think we can all agree on that
there we go Oh son agreement no there's
no [ __ ] in this room then what are
you - you're [ __ ] owners [ __ ] a
little bit of little 56k lag there so
all right the second term here that they
have is cricketing British [ __ ] it's
when you don't shave your legs and like
this is fun is it really that's pretty I
don't know that sounds legit actually
it's where you just talking [ __ ] from
the side I don't know go ahead quick
kidding oh when you're talking to
multiple people at night is when your
[ __ ] telegraphing give me that
[ __ ] oh yeah I think reckoning is when
you probably pull something against tree
I'm like hey what's everyone doing
tonight that's poor and by the way
that's like the loneliest [ __ ] you could
ever say don't do that oh my god I have
someone that I know that does that all
the time
well sorry that I just want some
companionship tonight
alright so cricketing is when people
deliberately leave a text message on
read for longer than is necessary
Oh with all cricketing cuz crickets baby
you know when you're just oh the awkward
awkward that's to touch their saying
like in some cases it can take days even
weeks for the other potential reply
really responsible I probably would have
done that that's a cool move that's a
real cool three days three rate before
[ __ ] games you talk to a chick you
meet her and then you get her number and
then you wait three days and you call
her right no they already texted you and
then you see it but you don't really
because you're so [ __ ] business yeah
even though you're just jerking off yeah
or I could apply to girls too
they're just chilling off no like this
seeing it never playing oh I see if they
don't keep my attention I run away you
know why because I get I have short-term
memory I don't know I don't even know
who they are anymore like you're walking
YouTube dude this cat has to put on
galoshes to wade through the [ __ ] dude
I see that trust me what took the lodge
[ __ ] galoshes like this big boots ago
anyways to the [ __ ] like it's like
you've just I guess Paul Townes went to
a [ __ ] hurt hand if I wear that
fly-fishing thing I'm calling all the
way back to Jess that's what I'm doing
that's a nice a nice yeah watches the
videos before they come up with you know
five baby good job give it to you uh
what do you guys think ghostbusting is
when you've come on a ghost when you run
into the [ __ ] I'm gonna go with
what are you come on a ghost yeah oh no
a real ghost
is it real come on ghosts come oh I
never even thought of that these jagged
off at the cemetery jacking up at the
cemetery I'm going with that goes
busking is when a person continues to
contact someone who is ignoring them
that is kind of sad that's just being
thirsty right oh isn't that being
thirsty yeah yeah you don't like you
can't put together the signs they don't
want to [ __ ] talk to your eyes
anymore alright in the next term here is
serendipity ting okay the chocolate the
rope this this is a tumbler thing yeah
sound like a tumbler no I can't you
don't
serendipity is when you're dating the /
same person twice on accident mmm
it's when you stick your dick in
chocolate it's when you go on your
intend to go on a date with somebody but
you end up on a date with somebody else
oh [ __ ] that means
serendipity yeah yeah the movie where
they're like if it's meant to be
all we serendipity did really I don't
know I guess all right no that's a
change of any means no to parents there
were two friends stuck in a car and then
we realized hey this is pretty cool well
I shared it once but I didn't like it
you know said I'm not gonna do it in
here do I even know what it is continue
exactly I'm trying to guess
okay so what's there in zipa dating
means is putting off of dates and hopes
that something better will come oh
that's that no I did what I did why
would you do such a thing that's so sad
for David they're like third place
that's world that we live in right now
with like dating a second tinder you can
get likes just access to so many people
oh that makes sense then yeah but here's
the truth everybody [ __ ] smell that's
an interesting truth in all those
pictures get ruined when you meet them
in person
I rather jack off the photos oh you
don't want to go and that's why I jack
off the photos as well as nobodies yeah
people that you see on the instagrams
that you're like this person is very
beautiful but when you meet them in
person they open their mouth it's like
it because it smells are after they say
dunk for their sake dumb [ __ ] but it
just sounds stupid it's like ah [ __ ] I
could have just left it in my brain and
you sounded way better and you were a
lot more intelligent people will always
disappoint you which is why you should
fear comfort has tagged your after
photos the PSA like it
hey it never fails yeah that I guess
what's so begging is following Oh
baiting like fake baying it's like a
millennial like eating another
millennial back in a [ __ ] circle like
it's like the Millennial centipede yeah
it is like that millennial centipede
yeah
what is this I don't know it's when a
single person pretends to have a partner
on social media oh just pretend you like
you have a bait like Nadine yeah it's
like to make their jealous or their ex
jealous oh like that girl who took a
photo with their legs BAE caught me
sleeping it just sounds like losers do
all this I just have too much time on
our hands
yeah that's a file out of it I don't
think it's a loser thing I just think
it's just young people thing oh really
yeah all these shoes we did this true
yeah just maybe just less annoying
sounding like oh that feels so sprung
you won't stop calling that girl and she
doesn't want him yeah cuz that's all we
did as cute like the only at this time
yeah do it man this is the whole being
single thing is so much work dude not
even now though like now it's not as bad
as it was just working Joe you have to
put up airs 24/7 when you start dating
you try to put on your best foot forward
I hate it now you just look like this
dude he's [ __ ] just chill dude don't
threaten me like that come on
[Music]